dans les bâtiments modernes et
fonctionnels de la mère et l'enfant
la maternité du centre hospitalier
universitaire de besançon un centre de
planification et d'éducation familiale a
été récemment installée la création de
ce centre fait suite à la loi de 1972
dont le but final est de lutter contre
l'avortement par la contraception
il a pour but principal de promouvoir la
contraception afin de mieux informer le
public
quant à la contraception et d'éviter les
accidents secondaires l'avortement
la première étape est la consultation
auprès du médecin spécialisé les
réunions d'information tenues par les
sages-femmes et le conseiller conjugal
viendront ensuite vous avez déjà des
enfants et vous consultez pourquoi
exactement aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
avez une idée sur le type de
contraception que vous pourriez adopté
vous avez choisi la piste vous en avez
entendu parler qui paraît le plus facile
c'est un médicament que la femme prend
durant trois semaines consécutives
tous les soirs habituellement pour ne
pas enfermer habitudes et au bout de
trois semaines de prise de ce médicament
il y a donc à reda du médicament et il
ya une hémorragie qu'on dit et manger
privations il ya donc des consultations
publiques au cours desquelles la femme
subit un examen gynécologique des plus
complets éventuellement si les
conditions le demande
elle subit des examens biologiques qui
me permettront de détecter des contre
indications à la contraception orale par
exemple saisir rapidement
c'est un stérilet en cuivre voilà voilà
le cuivre je précise que c'est assez
vilain de démonstration pour laver
l'affront du stérilet viril et en t elle
et la font douter il est l'actif jaune
que vous pouvez voir qui est à base
d'oeufs puis voilà
c'est ce qui le rend efficace vous venez
consulter et on vous place stérile et
vous partez avec le stérilet c'est
absolument la pause et indolore voilà
alors ce stérilet se placent dans
l'utérus
voilà et laisse passer le fil à peu près
de 1 à 2 cm ce serait préférable plutôt
en inox que sauf que depuis l'utérus
il n'y a aucun ennui à ce tapage à cette
adjonction de métal ou stérilet il se
passe une réaction inflammatoire ou pour
de ces petits ge
il ya de nombreuses cellules qui se crée
donc une réaction inflammatoire et
l'ovule ne peut pas rencontrer les
spermatozoïdes donc grand de grands buts
grande efficacité du sert il et nous
avons constaté tout simplement que le
nombre des femmes accouchent et qui
assistait à cette information du jeudi
soir qui a lu dans le connu que la
maternité est de plus en plus importante
des femmes s'intéressent bien plus et la
contraception